[Music]
all right
what's up everybody today TIFF and I are
leaving for Catalina Island Catalina
Island is a very very small island off
the shore of Los Angeles it's actually
part of LA County and I've actually
never been there it's like a very
closeby getaway destination for locals
here and not only are we going as a
romantic getaway but it's also a
birthday getaway for TIFF
over the years I've always gotten Tiff's
a lot of material things like jewelry
and purses bags and stuff like that and
I've come to learn although she
appreciates those things she would
rather have experiences and traveling
and non-tangible
joys of the world and I realized that
five years into our relationship I'm
actually really terrible at planning
these things because year after year I
never know how to throw parties properly
nor do I know how to plan trips properly
in a more romantic way because I always
end up asking someone like for example
one year I ended up asking Geo what
should I do for Tiff's birthday this
year and she came up with a list and you
know in that specific year we ended up
doing a yacht thing but it's just these
I just don't come to me easy I don't
know I feel like guys out there like
these things don't come to us easy I
don't know why but anyways this year
just no shame i straight-up asked - what
do you want to do this year for your
birthday and she mentioned Catalina
Island I'm doing this for her but I
think she's doing it for me and returned
because I've never been to Catalina
Island so I booked this whole thing to
celebrate her birthday but I think she
chose Catalina so that I could
experience Catalina Island for myself
anyways before we head out we are going
to make some food real quick get our
energy up and have a great awesome three
four four day getaway yeah
you're bringing Rilakkuma - yeah haven't
you noticed I've been bringing
villekulla every time you travel because
I noticed that I can't sleep without my
really combine anymore because my pillow
so I sleep alone are you saying that
you'd rather have Rilakkuma over me I
mean you replace yes yes I'm just
kidding you know I never had like a
stuffed animal when I was growing up and
I always wanted one there like my
blankie you know like kids just have
things like that I never really had one
for me but now that I'm a grown-ass
woman I have really cool I always wanted
to grow up and be a replacement teddy
bear yeah for my future awhile you know
and I can't even be that now you know
you get hot so true that never gets hot
so that's why I cuddle with really come
out but anyways you want to eat you all
right so today on the menu is chicken
breast and the last couple days we've
been eating meat loaf and fajitas we're
actually partnered up with
hellofresh for this video shout outs to
hellofresh hellofresh super easy if you
guys don't know what it is it's a meal
delivery service and so this time we
decided to check out hello fresh cuz the
recipes look delicious the recipes are
very rustic at least for this for the
Wednesday snack to us they're very
rustic it's just simple simple and fast
and then I love how everything's already
pre-measured for you and all you have to
do is just stick it in the fridge with
you
get it in your home and then once you're
ready to cook it you just whip it up and
it's so awesome cuz you can pick the
delivery day whenever it fits into your
busy schedule and then all the
ingredients are pre measured so it's
super easy just whip it up once you're
ready to cook and it's always delivered
right to your door and I love the fact
that they deliver it and recyclable
packaging so for example the bags that
the food comes in you can use that to
throw it away your scraps things like
that it's really cool because it's
healthy for the environment so there's
basically three types of meal plans that
you can choose from there's a classic
one where it provides you you know
variety of meat and fish there's veggie
ones which is pretty much a vegetarian
menu and then there's also a family one
which is like really easy recipes that
you know kids can also eat as well so
none of the flavors is too complex but
now so it's very flexible with type of
recipes that they provide for you again
I love it too because like I said I'm
not a cook at all I said this many times
and I yeah and so I love the fact that
hella fresh makes it super easy I'm able
to feel really confident when I'm
cooking because all the directions are
there I don't need to think I just have
to follow instructions and it's pretty
cool too because we get to try out
different kinds of food that we would
never really eat so or make oh yeah a
lot of stuff that never make because I
just don't know how those ingredients
mesh together and with these things I'm
like I'm learning honestly I mean the
last two meals you made I know the
meatloaf I know a meatloaf was my
favorite so if you guys want to make
your own hellofresh meal make sure to
check out hellofresh calm and then enter
our code tip case 30 and it'll give you
$30 off your first week with Hello fresh
so make sure to check them out guys it's
really delicious
we should eat though cuz once we're done
eating here we got to head out to the
ferry and go on my birthday
island adventure Bon Appetit
[Music]
we finally made it we were actually
really worried that we were gonna miss
the ferry because it was exactly 2:55
which is the time the ferry supposed to
take off and that's the exact time at
the Cooper dropped us off so we walked
into the terminal defeated we're like oh
we missed it and then they were like you
just don't catch it we're like what is
who your hands to the boat
if not we're planning our idiom getting
a motel somewhere near the port it's
gonna be like oh no we miss that I was
thinking man we underestimated the
Thanksgiving traffic I know we did
tomorrow
we're actually spending Thanksgiving in
Catalina Isaac
[Music]
we're standing outside for a good while
and we all fit
we weren't able to catch it on camera
though they left too quickly
I got calls and I start wearing a jacket
again before uncle ah I'm getting very
seasick so you learn that about myself
that I tend to get motion sickness the
only thing I don't get is hair
I guess but these say karstic throwing
up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome to a Catalina air B&B we just
got here the Sun went down he feels
really late but yeah we're here saving
six dead right now this is so freakin
cute and it's so tiny and it's like a
tiny little beach house careful is step
did a little elephant towel thing I was
reading online how small this place was
TIFF was personally telling me how small
this place was and I was like yes it's
small that's what I'm expecting when I
got here is still blew my mind how small
tiny they even drive golf carts
everywhere there's no cars it's like the
cutest tiniest little island and this is
our home for the next four days yeah we
don't have any work so that we owe ya
that's that's the reason why we're
celebrating your birthday early is
because the whole week is off in terms
of work yeah we're posting this on your
birthday
exactly look at this good thing they
don't forget okay let's see what's in
the fridge
oh it's hoping for some free ice cream
no really hey we gotta go buy that
though yeah we gotta stocked up for the
next three days yeah we got to get some
dinner right now all right bye guys
let's go how was your massage it was
wonderful it was so amazing like she was
so good she started off with my arms
first and when she finished the first
one I started thinking like oh my god
that was so amazing I'm so excited for
my next arm to experience what she just
did like so relaxed now alright what are
we doing next
next we're gonna go eat I am very hungry
my stomach was grumbling in the
beginning of the massage I was like oh
no
[Music]
we rented electric bike so now we're
just riding around they had three
electric bikes one of them was like
peach and then the other two are these
colors which is like our channel colors
so - teal and then you got the red Sun
is setting so we have to hurry and
explore the rest of the island goes
through how you're gonna film with one
hand we'll see what happens I don't know
[Music]
oh dear
[Music]
I put that before those but do it
you're so cool getting kind of cold I'm
cold I don't know how you're surviving
that t-shirt and shorts
do you feel like here in 1930s now for
19 points
[Music]
oh yeah it's just so nice the music just
got made yeah happy birthday thank you
baby
what little work then let the other
columns behind you
it's actually really romantic
[Music]